CNN has learned that Britain is giving Ukraine new
long-range strike capability. Sources tell us that
the uk has delivered multiple storm shallow cruise
missiles to Kyiv. It comes as Ukrainian forces
prepare for a long awaited counteroffensive
in the south and east. Ukraine's president
has said that his country needs a bit more time
before launching that counteroffensive though,
as it awaits the delivery of more military aid
from the west. When it does happen, the head of
Ukraine's -- energy agency says Ukrainian forces
will have to go around this a power plant to avoid
damaging the facility. CNN senior international
correspondent, Sam kiley, had a chance to sit
down one-on-one with Ukraine's nuclear chief
and he joins us now, live from Kyiv. Sam,
there have been numerous threats to the safety
of this power stations for months now. Artillery,
drones, dikes power cuts, and now concerns
about the drain of qualified personnel.
[8:06:56 AM]
personnel.
>>
Yeah, it is a concern, although it's not one,
funnily enough, that the Ukrainians are being
too exercised about. That is because even though
they say they believe that -- which is the town
next to the nuclear power station is already
being evacuated of Russian officials and that
there are plans to move Russians and other
officials nuclear workers out of the plant,
there are still enough low Ukrainians there
to run things. It's very telling, indeed,
when I spoke to him earlier on today, Bianca,
about how he was describing plans even among the
Russian nuclear workers to get out of dodge before
this offensive starts. This is what he said.
>> They're probably, right now
trying to be prepared for quick
getting out. Also, -- more recently it's
a drill. >> So, Bianco, we're seeing if
[8:08:04 AM]
>> So, Bianco, we're seeing if it was rather he
saying that these evacuation drills even among
the Russian officials run in the nuclear power
station, there were 1500 he says that he would
imagine them staying on and yet more in the
town if they're not forced out of that town,
then we'll be able to step into the nuclear
facility to carry on running. It he also said
that the Ukrainians's, very clear from the
military perspective that there's no need no
intention to try to recapture the nuclear power
station because in his view they could actually
cut down and separate the nuclear power station
from Russian forces in the crimea and that's
Thank you very. Much >> Now Ukraine where
Russian forces are facing setbacks in the
battle for bakhmut. The officials say they have
conducted a successful counterattack in the city,
inflicting huge losses on Russian fighters.
There's no course as the Wagner boss is getting
rages yet again about Russian leaders. He is
demanding more ammunition and support. Sam kiley
joins me now from Kyiv. Sam, you and I have spoken
at length about this. The battle for bakhmut has
been the longest and bloodiest in this war. Do we
know how this was achieved and whether Ukraine can
replicated elsewhere? This one in bakhmut?
>>
Well, it is an extraordinary turn of
events. One area with just about two
kilometers was cleared. Both Ukrainians
and pro-governors agree, I rushing
[2:14:38 PM]
pro-governors agree, I rushing it called the 72nd
brigade was abandoning in the flank on to the
south of bakhmut. That is his allegation. Russian
military -- has said that it was Wagner who left
the flank. They were not driven out, they simply
concentrated their forces elsewhere. And there
was no Russian military they are to cover it.
The Ukrainians exploited that by talking. Now
the Ukrainians have released images of heavy
fighting there. And significant losses among
the Russians there. Climbing very high losses
indeed among the Russians. I think it's wise
not to use the figures in a combat in terms of
the numbers of enemies that they have killed.
What is interesting here is that Russian
military bloggers on the scene of a well
plugged into the military structures, pointing
to a complete lack of coordination between the
formal structures within the Russian armed forces
and the Wagner group on the tip of the spear,
[2:15:41 PM]
group on the tip of the spear, effectively.
The fight for bakhmut. If that is the,
case and that is a systemic failure, that
means that the Russians are in pretty poor
order to face up to what is likely
to be a much wider problem for them,
when the Ukrainians launched their must
vaunted spring summer offensive. Which
are anticipated to be sometime this month, Isa.
>> Just to clarify, Sam. Prigozhin, who leaves
the released evac near group, said a couple
of days ago, I think, I've lost track of time,
that his troops would leave by may the 9th.
We didn't get supplies and ammunition. Any
surprise to this? What are you hearing?
>> He said that they would leave by may
the 9th. And then he said he was promised
ammunition. Now he is saying that the
ammunition did not turn up. It is part of
the ongoing soap opera, really, and which
he has been bitterly critical for many months
now, indeed, of the formal structures of the
[2:16:41 PM]
formal structures of the Russian armed forces
all the way through to the top. He is using
expletive laden attacks on general grab some
of, the head of the armed forces of Russia.
Defense minister shoigu, all of these characters.
They are happy to lampoon and lambast in his
postings. I think this really is part potentially
of his efforts to position himself in the future.
Perhaps for some kind of political role. Very
difficult to work out how he is doing this,
and why he is doing it. What it does do is
show that there are frictions and frailties
within the Russian command structure, that
Ukrainians are exploiting. And they're
certainly going to exploit further.
>> Fractures we have seen for